tomorrow marks the first night of
hanukkah the eight-day jewish festival
of lights a holiday that in part
celebrates the idea of hope of spiritual
resilience feelings which over the last
three years the jewish community in
squirrel hill and neighborhood of
pittsburgh have come to rely upon in
october of 2018 11 jews were murdered
while worshiping in a local synagogue
the horrific attack is the subject of a
new book squirrel hill the tree of life
synagogue and the soul of a neighborhood
we visited squirrel hill with author
mark oppenheimer to explore how the
entire community rallied illuminating
the idea of hope to overcome the
darkness of hate
this is ellesboro avenue this is where
my dad grew up mark oppenheimer can
trace his family history back three
generations here in squirrel hill
a pittsburgh neighborhood
that has held fast to its roots since
its founding around the time of world
war one i pretty quickly picked up on
the fact that there was something
special about this that it had had this
stable jewish minority for 100 years and
that it was it was unique in american
history while oppenheimer grew up
outside the area he was shaken when
squirrel hill became the site of the
deadliest anti-semitic attack in
american history
he's firing out of the front of the
building with an automatic weapon
on october 27 2018
robert bowers entered the tree of life
synagogue with three handguns and a
semi-automatic rifle
he's accused of fatally shooting 11
people and wounding six others
everyone killed was jewish
members of three separate congregations
using the same synagogue to worship and
i pretty quickly realized that
i had something of a calling to write
about this not just as a journalist
who's covered religion but also as
someone with a very personal stake in
this particular neighborhood oppenheimer
visited squirrel hill 32 times
interviewing more than 200 people for
what ultimately became his latest book
squirrel hill the tree of life synagogue
shooting and the soul of a neighborhood
one of the things that people pointed
out to me was that these ties both among
jews of different denominations but also
between jews and muslims jews christians
these weren't ties that they created on
october 27 2018 the morning or afternoon
of the killing that this was a
neighborhood of people who turned out
for each other not just online or not
just in phone calls but physically that
people bumped into each other at these
stores
at these little shops at these
family-owned businesses and hugged each
other and cooked for each other and
really did for each other not just in
digital space but in real life analog
space it's that neighborhood bond
oppenheimer details in his book like the
steps taken by strangers within the
jewish community to ensure religious
traditions were followed for the dead
despite the chaos that comes with a mass
shooting pittsburgh is very special in
that the squirrel hill jewish community
has a lot of cooperation between the
orthodox the conservative reform secular
jews all the different communities have
not just what you would call interfaith
cooperation but intra faith and jews
that's not always the case and that is
not always the case the book also
contains accounts from survivors like
rabbi jonathan perlman he escaped the
building but three members of his new
light congregation were killed it's been
over three years
but
for you personally does it feel like you
are that far removed from that day
no i i feel it's like it's uh
you know still with me
it seems like it happened yesterday you
know i look at the faces of
members of our school
and they
just don't know what to say but rabbi
perlman is consoled by memories of how
people of all backgrounds supported one
another in a time of need i'm glad the
testimony about
the shooting is out there for people to
read about
and the ways in which the entire region
can come together to say when you are
hateful towards one group within our
circle
we are going to repel you and we are
going to stand in solidarity with these
people make sure that they are protected
it's a message the neighborhood
continues to send with images created in
the wake of the shooting ever present
the non-jewish manager of the starbucks
got a non-jewish roman catholic friend
of hers who was an artist to come paint
jewish symbols in the windows this
stronger than hate symbol quickly became
synonymous with squirrel hill
oppenheimer dug into its origins and
found graphic designer tim hines you're
not jewish right i'm not jewish why did
you feel compelled to do something yeah
i wanted to show my support
that was something that was really
important to me was showing my support
and solidarity i started with the simple
image of
the steel logo
and uh you know swapped out a uh
uh one of those diamonds for for a star
of david and uh swapped out the steel
name and and added stronger than hate
heinz made the image available for free
it was downloaded more than twenty
thousand times
the only way that we're going to
rid ourselves of hate is to continually
spread acts of love and
whatever skill set someone has whether
it's graphic design or whether it's
the ability to clean up someone's yard
you know those acts of love go a long
way in battling hate the synagogue is
still not in use no one has prayed
inside it since that morning on the
fences still surrounding the tree of
life synagogue it is depictions of love
and unity that you find today
there's some people who want to go back
inside and use that same space as a
tribute to the victims there are other
people who feel that the best thing they
can do for the community is never use
that space again and reconfigure the
inside to do something different this
right now is so powerful obviously i
haven't been here before but seeing
the stars of david in the
in the building it's real it really is
impactful
a reminder of the hate that visited
squirrel hill but also of the hope that
followed what did you find in this
community is it stronger now than it
even was before
i don't know that you could measure any
community strength in such a way that
you could say it's stronger but it's
definitely as strong there are
communities in america that after a mass
killing have come apart at the seams
where people are at each other's throats
they're fighting over money they're
fighting over how to memorialize the
bodies they're fighting over what to do
with buildings there have been suicides
of survivors
and what you can say is that none of the
worst things that could have happened
have come to squirrel hill they managed
to dodge all the worst case scenarios
and i think that is a tribute to the
pre-existing strength of the
neighborhood ties
and just being in that community for the
day you really could feel this bond and
i know maybe that's not unique just to
squirrel hill that there are other
communities like that but it made such a
difference as the healing continues you
know rabbi perlman told me he hasn't
read this book he doesn't watch the
reports about it he is still in the
healing process as so many others are i
remember being there immediately after
and he is absolutely right what he
points out in that story is that people
came to support other people in person
right not just with phone calls or
online it was being there physically to
support them it's the fact that it
happened it's such a sacred place and
when that happens
you can't even touch the anger and also
the hope that we can get better in
making our world
more loving and that's what they want to
focus on is that hope that comes from
that moment of hate